- And speaking of Nashville,
you had country music star ambitions,
you wanted to be a country
singer and I had no idea.
- I did.
Kelly, as wild as that sounds,
and you'll appreciate this, obviously,
because of your love for music
and certainly country music too.
I grew up loving blues, hip hop, of course
but then country, but
real traditional country,
like that three chords and the truth,
steel guitar kind of country.
And when I got to Nashville,
I started hanging out,
because I didn't have a lot of friends,
because they all thought
I was an undercover cop.
So, I started hanging out on Broad Street,
and you know Broad
Street where Tootsies is
and the Ryman Auditorium,
and I loved country music--
- On Broadway, yeah.
- At that time and I had
this fantasy in my head.
So, the story goes like this.
I was at a grocery store
and I was shopping,
and when I say shopping,
I was actually doing a
little five-finger discount,
at that time, because I
couldn't afford anything.
So, and I was in the middle of the row
in the shopping aisle, and
I was belting out this song,
not caring who was listening to me.
And then, a woman comes around the corner
and she sticks her head around the corner
and she looks, and I stopped singing.
She looks at me, her eyes
go wide and she's like,
"Wow, I did not expect to see
"someone who looks like
you singing that song."
And I said, "Oh, thank you."
And then we had this
chat and she was like,
(laughs) she goes, "So clearly,
"you should go down to Broad Street,
"'cause that's where the
country singers are."
- On Broadway, yeah.
- I didn't tell her I was 15
and I had no business being
in a bar at that time.
But then, I went down
there, on Broad Street,
and I used to hang out down there
and listen to all the acts
and I did have it in my mind
that I was gonna become
a country music singer.
Then, I realized that singing in keys
that don't exist might not
be (laughs) of good value.
- No, you can't say that.
You're so full of it.
You were great in "Moana."
I was like, "What?"
I had no idea. So then, when
I found out the country thing,
I was like, "Oh, and you
married a singer/songwriter.
"This is all starting to make sense
"of where your career is headed."
So, here's my thing.
We sing on this show a lot.
So, I'm just saying if you
and your wife just stop by,
like we should all sing together sometime.
I'm just saying, or on cheat
day, we'll just hang out.
- We've got to, we gotta
do, let's do it, I'm down.
Let's do a duet.
- I'm down.
♪ Islands in the stream ♪
There we go. I am down.
I have done that.
Well, actually, the only
time I've sing that song
is drunk at a karaoke bar.
(Kelly laughs)
I don't think I've remember
sang that song sober.
That's fine.